NARRATOR: What makes
this photo so unusual
is not the fact that this
guy is suspended hundreds
of feet above the ground off
the edge of the sheer cliff.
No.
It's that he's hanging there
with some sort of giant drill
gun.
It seems like an odd place
to do construction, so
what exactly is he doing?
The photographer rappelling
right above him was this guy.
MATTHEW PARENT: Hi there.
My name is Matthew Parent.
I am a freelance photographer
and filmmaker based out
of Los Angeles, California.
This photo was taken just
outside Chihuahua, Mexico,
in a climbing area
called Nuevo Majalca.
This photo is of my good
friend and fellow climbing
partner, Gaz Lee.
He is a prolific route setter.
NARRATOR: Route setters
aren't the people you normally
think about when it comes to
the sport of rock climbing.
That's because whenever
you watch a person climb,
the routes have most likely
already been set before them,
but people like Gaz go
searching for untouched cliffs
and boulders and design
their own routes to traverse.
And that's what Gaz was
doing in this photo.
He used the drill to
set bolts in the rock
as anchors for climbers
to latch onto for safety.
MATTHEW PARENT:
Climbing development
is a very serious thing.
There are a lot of
ways you can mess up,
and if you don't
do it correctly,
someone can die on your route.
To get this photo,
we actually had
to haul about 30 to
40 pounds of gear
up the backside of this
loose gravelly cliff.
Swapping lenses 200
feet off the ground
is one of the most interesting
experiences I'll ever have.
NARRATOR: Not to
mention dangerous.
You've got to have a lot of
trust in your climbing partner
to reach heights like this.
It's a bond that's often
built over years of friendship
and climbing experience,
but for Matt and Gaz,
the day this photo was
taken, it was the first time
the two had ever met in person.
The two were at
Nuevo Majalca working
for the nonprofit, Escalando
Fronteras, an organization that
connects kids living in at
risk and underdeveloped areas
to rock climbing.
MATTHEW PARENT: We just
kind of linked up online
and decided that, hey, we should
probably go on this adventure
together.
So I flew in.
He picked me up.
We drove immediately
to Chihuahua,
where he was teaching
a bolting clinic
for local Mexican climbers.
NARRATOR: The sport isn't
very popular in Mexico,
but this is exactly why
Matt and Gaz were there--
to carve out new
routes that had never
been climbed before for a small
community eager to learn how.
MATTHEW PARENT:
It has to be said
that the local climbing
community in Mexico
is absolutely beautiful.
I mean the people you
meet when you travel
are more often than not the
most friendly, hospitable,
warm people you could
ever possibly meet.
And with Mexico, especially,
this is no exception.
People take you in.
They feed you.
They laugh with you.
They drink with you.
Every moment is just
absolutely fantastic,
and they're so excited
to show you around
and to show you
this climbing area
that they feel
like ownership for.
It's a breathtaking area,
and to capture moments
like this that show a side of
the world and a side of society
that not many people were
aware of is a wonderful thing.
NARRATOR: To see
even more adventures
from around the globe, watch
this episode on the left.
It's about the race to
the end of the world.
Or check out this one on
the right about hunting
in the wild with
adventurer Donnie Vinson.
And as always, don't
forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.